hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
today's sunday and i'm a property
investor so you know what that means
that means that i'm gonna answer all of
your property investment questions
and honestly i do this every single
sunday and i've helped
hundreds and hundreds of people become
financially free through investing in
property
as a result of videos like these so if
you like my channel please do me a
massive favor
all i ask is that you smash the like
button and also subscribe
turn the notification bell on and let's
see what questions we had last week also
if you've got a question around property
investment tax
mortgages rent to rent lease option
agreements or anything property related
whatsoever
comment below and then next sunday at 7
pm
i'm going to answer your property
investment questions
it's free to ask questions and have me
answer them i've been investing in
property now for 12 years
i've made millions of pounds investing
in property and i'm going to be
answering all your questions so get
commenting below right now
so last week we had a guy called joe
summer hey joe he said
thank you for teaching me so far i love
your content and enthusiasm thank you my
question is
should you estimate the return on
investment on properties you find
if so how do you estimate the pricing of
legal
stamp duty etc or should you wait until
you know all pricing of legal stamp duty
etc to work out the roi properly
many thanks keep up the great work so
joe um
yeah working out the return on
investments real simple it's just a case
of well i say it's real simple but
the yield is real simple and everyone
talks about yield
and yield is just simply a case of
dividing the annual rent
by the purchase price or by the value of
the property so if it's a
if the properties make bringing 10 000
pounds a year in rent
and the property is a 100 000 pound
house the yield is 10 percent
you are correct though in the return on
investment is a little bit more complex
it factors in different costs
like what's the mortgage payments going
to be what's the legal costs what's the
stamp duty
so you probably should begin to get an
idea of how much that those things are
going to be
i mean to give you an idea legal costs
might be depend it depends
it really depends it might be a thousand
pounds um or so
in legal fees to buy a house but of
course there's many different factors
involved
stamp duty typically is three percent
but again it depends
depends on the house are you going to be
moving into the house to live there
um or are you going to be doing it as an
investment property if it's an
investment property
is it inhabitable if it's inhabitable
you won't pay stamps youtube
but if it's already an up-and-running
budget that you will so there are
different factors
you really do need to get a bit of an
idea and i'd say the best way to
to really learn that is is just to keep
watching videos like this
maybe go on the hmrc website and see
what the stamp duty rules are
and when you pay stamp duty when you
don't and also it really is just
experience
so i i don't know if that helps maybe it
doesn't but
if you've got a follow-up question to
that answer comment it below and i'll do
my best to help next time as well
great question thanks so much joe okay
brian arnold
how do you avoid the three percent on on
stamp duty land tax for multiple
properties
i'm about to own one two one i live in
and want to rent out
um great question brian so stamp duty on
multiple properties so if you're buying
lots of properties at the same time i
think it's six properties
i think it's six properties it might be
four i'll have to check that i've
i have managed to do this several times
when i'm buying a portfolio off of a
landlord
uh also if i'm if you're buying a
property that's got lots of properties
in one
um i've bought blocks before that have
got lots of different apartments and
you'll get multiple dwelling relief
which will save you one stamp duty
um so if you're just buying one or two
properties though
this probably isn't going to apply to
you because it is i think it's six
but it's definitely not less than four
so you might have to just take stamp
duty on the chin
and sometimes you just have to pay tax
and that's okay you know i don't mind
paying tax
i'll pay as little as i can but
sometimes you have to pay
and you need to look at the bigger
picture of how much you're going to be
making on the deal rather than focusing
on how much
you're going to have to i mean i prefer
to just worry about making money you
know
some people get so obsessed with trying
to save every penny i say look after the
penalties too closely and you'll
you'll lose the million hope that helps
adam says
in my twenties landlord owned four by
tillette
three family let's one hmo working full
time in property
remortgage is done on each properties
thank you for your videos what's next
how do i grow further and take things to
the next level
capital required okay so i'm i'm not
sure whether when you say capital
required that means that you've got the
capital because you mentioned that you
just refinanced
so i don't know if you've got money or
if you haven't got money but whether you
have or not my advice would be the same
i would say
firstly congratulations you're in your
20s and you've got a little portfolio
going which is fantastic
i would use your current experience
to leverage more money and you can i
mean i mean banks care about your
experience but so do investors
and if you've got a track record have
been able to show that you can make
money in property
you've bought hmos they're going
successfully what you could now do is
you could find an investor even even a
private investor
and you can say look this is what i've
previously done you know here's the
stats here's what i've done
how about you put the money in i'll find
the deal and we'll do it we'll do a
profit share we'll do a joint venture so
i would
definitely be looking to do that joint
ventures are the way to go most
development deals are done by joint
ventures
most people that have become very
successful in property have done it via
joint ventures so
you know you want to go fast go alone
you want to go fargo together so that my
advice adam
would be to bring people in on the deals
and also go bigger start scaling up and
doing bigger deals
um because it takes just as much energy
and effort on a small deal as it does a
big deal so every time you buy a new
deal
go a little bit bigger push yourself at
your comfort zone hope that helps
mr sgs says firstly thank you and god
bless for you do to help people that's
you're so so so welcome my question is
can i
access the government grants or loans
like uni
ones to get into your academy um
i don't think so i don't think the
government will give you a grant to get
into my academy i mean
listen the system the government the
education system
it's all created for you to go get a job
okay
my training is very different my
training is all created for you to be
able to become financially independent
and for you to be able to retire young
retire rich live life on your terms
build a property empire so it's kind of
a different
game plan so if you start going to the
government asking them for loans to go
on my training programs
i don't think they're gonna say yes uh
maybe there is funding
maybe there are loans and stuff you can
get um
but i'm not too sure but be very happy
to talk to you about that
so if you find any let me know if you
find any grants
all right josh warburton please can you
speak about what certificates and
licenses you need to become a landlord
just with a normal buy to let so listen
in the
rules of business everyone everyone who
cares and thinks about certificates and
licenses and all that kind of stuff
usually are very much in the job
mentality
um you don't genuinely need any
certificates or any licenses
any qualifications to buy and rent out a
house
now there are some areas where this is
not the case there are some types of
properties where this is not the case
for example if you're buying a property
in wales
which i do own properties in wales you
do need a
license to buy a property in wales now
to get a license is really easy it costs
a hundred pounds
and you just fill out a form it's very
very easy to get one
but you do uh if you're buying a hmo
property
and there's five or more people living
in the hmo you need a hmo license
again very easy to get it's more about
the property than it is about you about
the property being suitable so
you do sometimes need licenses but
generally speaking you do not
to be an entrepreneur to make money
normally there's not that i mean if you
want to be a doctor
you got to go to university you got to
get this you got to get that and it's a
big process or you want to be a lawyer
or a doctor or something like that
but to be an entrepreneur there's very
little formal education that you need
however i do strongly believe that you
need self-education
jim rohn says that self-education will
make you a fortune
but traditional formal education will
make you a living and i couldn't agree
with that more
hope that helps josh okay rohit
lol i've asked a question on four of
your videos and none have ever been
answered
hmm sorry about that rohit uh i don't
know what your question is
maybe if you've asked me a fifth time i
would have actually seen it come up but
i
can't really help you now so hope to see
your question one more time
okay burning desire i have a 75 000
property which comes with headaches like
every four to six weeks i get a call to
fix something like the pipe leak in the
bathroom or kitchen
my question is should my next one be a
better house like 150
000 pound worth to attract better
tenants
i feel the higher end houses will
appreciate more in the future
and i want to make wealth in this
recession yes the rental yields would be
a lot less but i think capital growth is
key
in recessions am i on the right lines
great question i feel your pain i mean
honestly it's so annoying when you have
a house and every
you know six weeks something breaks in
it i don't think that's so much to do
with
the house being a cheap house though i
think it might be more to do with i mean
i own a lot of cheap houses but i've
refurbished them to a high standard i've
bought them really cheap in cheap areas
and then i've refurbed them refinance
them and they don't have any problems
because they've been done up to a really
high standard
uh sometimes if you've got a house
that's a bit old inside or it's a very
old house and
they there can be houses that are
particularly problem prone um
and that can be the case with a 75 grand
house or 150 grand house
so i don't think going for a more
expensive house is necessarily the way
forward
i mean the house that i live in i rent
this house and
geez my landlord's always having to pay
for things and fix things like the gate
breaks and it's like
two grand to fix the to fix the electric
gate so
having a more expensive house doesn't
necessarily mean no repairs and no
maintenance issues i think the answer is
to have your house done to a good stat
standard and of course yes for sure if
your house is in a bad area
and it's you know really rough tenants
and stuff then that is potentially going
to be a problem
but you don't need to buy a house really
expensive to get it in a decent area you
just need to buy a house in a decent
area
i mean there's areas around london where
you'll buy a house for half a million
pounds and it's in a very rough area
with very bad tenants
and then there's areas in um leeds
where you can buy a house for 150 grand
and it's in a really nice area
or even cheaper so i hope that gives you
a bit of a bit of food for thought
thanks for your question i appreciate
you as a subscriber burning desire
james life hi samuel case study
one 200 000 pound house in city centre
near the university
or two one hundred thousand pound houses
outside of the city centre
near another university campus roi
is pretty much the same wondering if the
benefit of having two properties
outweighs the ease of one so
james i'm very surprised that the roi is
the same but if the roi is genuinely the
same
i would probably buy one house however
normally speaking a hundred grand house
and a 200 grand house
the rent on the 200 house is not going
to be double
there is no direct correlation between
the house price and the rent
so normally you will get a better return
by leveraging your money and buying
multiple houses but if the other was
genuinely the same i'd probably just buy
one because less tenants
is less headaches eki can a housing
association tenant get a buy to let
mortgage
i don't see why not yeah i mean listen
buy to let mortgage
this is business this is business now if
you're buying a residential mortgage
they care about you
they care all about you if you're buying
a buy to let property
and getting a buy to let mortgage they
just care about the afford they just
care about
whether they're going to get the
mortgage paid they care about the house
more than anything so
if you're a housing association tenant i
can't say they're gonna judge you and be
like
no you can't get a mortgage because you
are housing association then i don't
think so
speak to a mortgage advisor though and
uh see what they say
all right last one ben says is it
possible to succeed in property if i am
shy um yeah a hundred percent
i mean also shy is a very interesting
word now if you're
introverted which just means that you're
not massively into hanging
an introvert is someone who gets energy
from being alone they like to be alone
an extrovert is someone who gets energy
from being with people i like being with
other people
introverted people that might be a
little bit quiet by nature and not love
being around people all the time
can they succeed absolutely yes 100
shy people depends what you mean by shy
by shy if you mean
timid and scared no you're not going to
succeed because
because shyness is almost a and again
this might be controversial but i almost
see shyness as like
um almost a disease it's it's like if
when you say it depends on you shy if
you've been introverted
not at all no problem no problem if you
mean
timid scared what people think you know
that then i would say that's a sickness
and you need to get
get get stretch yourself you know
because listen
even if you're really extrovert and even
if you're loud and stuff like
people might see me and think i'm really
loud i'm really extrovert
do you think i felt shy before going to
a networking event the first time
uh-huh do you think before i went in i
was i was shaking and nervous
yes why because i've never done it
before do you think i when
the first time i went into an estate
agent's shop and told them i was looking
for below market value deals
do you think i was shy yeah i was my
mouth was drying up
i couldn't get my words out
because i've never done it before so
it's very normal to feel like that
but you have to push through that you
have to say actually you know what
i'm i'm going to get out of my comfort
zone because people that don't step out
of their comfort zone
aren't going to grow and aren't going to
get different results so depends what
you mean by shy
introverted no problem but if you if
you're just going to say i'm shy
therefore i'm not going to do that that
thing that's not you being shy that's
just you being a [ __ ]
like oh i'm shy to go into this estate
agent i'm shy to pick up the phone and
put a video i'm shocked
no no just go do it but if you're an
introverted person
no problem whatsoever i've i've helped a
lot of introverts become wildly
successful
so i hope that helps let to know your
thoughts and comments drop it in the in
the comment box below
also if you've got questions about
property
put them in the comment box i've done
over 300 property deals
so i kind of know what i'm talking about
when it comes to property and i come on
this channel
every single day do a youtube video and
every week sunday at 7 i'll answer your
questions so comment down below
smash the like button subscribe turn the
notification bell on
because if you haven't got the
notification bell on i might answer your
question
and you don't even know i answered it
because it didn't pop up and you didn't
see the video so turn it on and i look
forward to seeing you next time thanks
so much